the prodigy centers around a boy that
possesses a genius intellect but also
has a more sinister side to him that
comes out throughout the course of the
film the movie itself has a lot to
unpack from it and throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the film and its
ending there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you don't want to know anything
about the movie then I highly suggest
that you turn off now for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to the film opens on the thrash
Creek slasher a serial killer that
tortures young women the mass murderer
takes a lot of inspiration from Ted
Bundy and uses charm to entice girls in
before kidnapping and killing them the
killer's calling card is cutting off the
victims right hand and he's pretty
widely feared however during one murder
that would turn out to be his last his
victim manages to escape and alert the
police who kill him
the serial killer dies at the exact same
time that child is born and this sets up
the events of the film The Prodigy
diverts from the evil child aesthetic
that we've seen in movies like The Omen
The Exorcist and more by actually
focusing on reincarnation because the
trash Creek slasher had unfinished
business
the killer is left in limbo and is able
to inhabit and share a body with a newly
born baby named miles this is symbolized
by the fact that miles has two
differently colored eyes and showcases
his connection with the killer who had
the same thing miles seemed miles ahead
of people his age sorry for the pun
there and it's clear that the boy is
advanced beyond his years throughout the
film he has conversations with himself
in Hungarian which is the language that
the killer spoke and it's clear that the
two are aware of one another in the film
we learn that at the age of eight the
more dominant personality will take full
control of the body and the film
predominantly centers around Miles at
this age after causing trouble and
seeming like he has a sinister side his
parents send him to a specialist who
studies reincarnation and states that
it's a naturally occurring part of the
universe and we often get evidence
towards this in child birth it suggested
that at the age of eight the full
control of the body makes the child lose
their memory
and this is why reincarnation stories
often end up with memories of the past
life of being forgotten we are then told
that in order for the spirit of the
serial killer - leave my else's body
they must complete his final kill and
with his mother at the to go and murder
the thrash creep slashes final victim
whilst this should finally free miles we
actually learn that the killer has been
in control of the body for a long time
and has only been pretending to be two
people so that he can manipulate those
around him into allowing his killing
spree to continue miles his mother
realizes this and just as she is about
to kill him her neighbor stops by and
kills her this is understandable as in
the neighbors mind that they were merely
stopping the death of a child
however this allows the killer to put
back up the pretense of being a young
boy and we see down the line that miles
has been adopted by a new family and is
once again working on carrying out his
killing spree on a whole new set of
victims thus ending the film the movie
is much better on a second watch as you
are able to see the killer keep up the
pretense of being two people at once and
elevates it slightly which of course
adds a lot of weight to the eventual
twist similar to the omen as I mentioned
earlier it's great when a horror
subverts your expectations and has an
unhappy ending that shows that the good
guys don't always win I had a lot of fun
with The Prodigy and would definitely
love to hear your thoughts on it if you
agree or disagree make sure you leave
them in the comments below and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the new child's play trailer that was
shown before the movie which will be
linked at the end this is the channel
for people who were mad into movies so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace